à attention grosse question là encore
question existentielle mesdames
messieurs mesdames qui nous regardaient
messieurs qui nous regardent et pourriez
vous envisager d'avoir des relations
sexuelles avec un collègue de travail à
tout le monde
il ya un silence de mort tout le monde
regarde ses chaussures
ça arrive assez souvent et il y aurait
tout de même quelques règles à respecter
je t aime et sait nous en dit plus
généralement que tout est remis au
niveau esthétique au niveau social au
niveau intellectuel les gens essayent de
briller ou d'être le mieux possible
aussi bien au niveau esthétique
stylistiques ou autre et ça crée une
certaine attirance on a plus d'un
salarié sur deux qui lui dit qu'il a
déjà été attirée sexuellement par un
collègue
tous ne sont pas passés à l'acte mais on
a quand même
16% des personnes en couple qui ont déjà
une relation extra conjugale avec une
personne rencontrée sur leur lieu de
travail
le magazine elle donne aussi quelques
règles à respecter
évitez les rapports hiérarchiques
s'assurer qu'il ou elle n'est pas mariée
ne pas en parler à ses collègues alala
penser à trouver un nouveau job au cas
où ça tournerait mal alors pas mariés se
taire pas de remporter hiérarchique
qu'est ce que vous en pensez caroline
est ce que j'en pense c'est que c'est
pas envisagé c'est que ça va nous tomber
sur le nez un moment donné vous savez
qu'il faisait bien mais il ya 60% des
des gens dans un bureau qui fantasme sur
leurs collègues c'est bien que la salle
à part et remboursés mais sur qui jimmy
par exemple totalement fantasmé sur vous
non et omonia on est en cas en mode les
deux une montée en pression trop de
stress on n'est pas bien vu robin
rapprochement il s'avoue de belo monte
en pression et donc des coûts montent en
pression vous vous il entasse messieurs
christophe carrière ce que je sais c'est
que moi j'ai rencontré mon amoureux sur
mon lieu de travail
ce n'est pas un hasard je ne suis pas la
seule et ça l'a tous
alors il ya un mois sur le lieu de
travail très bien de répondre à la
question qu'est ce que vous en pensez
jimmy bosch traille seul
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
extrapolons élargissons on patiente un
peu sympa mais je vous dis aux bons
soins docteur non alors dans la vie de
tous les jours là je suis très jovial
très marrante un peu moins sympa dans la
vie de tous les jours
pardonnez moi là vous vous trouvez j'ai
vu à la chaux maxima d'accord c'est
qu'on va tabler sur 7